concerne les messieurs ici julie drolet
bienvenue à l'émission mais oui malaise
aujourd'hui pendant cette dernière
journée de la commission parlementaire
sur les seuils d'immigration à québec un
accrochage en fait entre le représentant
du haut commissariat aux réfugiés de
l'onu il s'appelle jean nicolas buzz et
le ministre de l'immigration sinon je
les barrettes voyez d'abord comment ça
s'est passé pour faire attention que
cette dichotomie qui tendent à dire que
les réfugiés sont un poids comme vous
espérez vous essayez de le souligner en
ce moment ce n'est pas forcément la
réalité que l'on voit quand on regarde
les bénéfices bmx au sujet de la nature
et alain broillet je n'ai jamais dit que
les réfugiés d'un poids je n'ai jamais
dit dans mon propos les propos que vous
me prêtez ne sont pas acceptables
le ton des changes est un petit peu
étonnant le porte parole de québec
solidaire en immigration andrée santé
cia était lui aussi dans la salle on
écoute sa réaction
il était sur la défensive il s'attaque
pas au fond aux fondus au fond de la
question et c'est à dire les opinions du
de notre invité est notre invité quand
même mais il savait qu'à la farmer est
ce que vous avez le droit de dire ce qui
vous a donné la permission comment les
déductions ces prêts mais j'étais bien
donc c'est une position de faiblesse à
mon avis pour savoir finalement à ce qui
en est de toute cette histoire j'ai reçu
jean-nicolas buzz la porte parole le
représentant du haut commissariat des
nations unies pour les réfugiés
je n'ai reçu donc un petit peu plus tôt
sur cet échange bonjour à ce buzz
bonjour ça a été un peu difficile votre
charge aujourd'hui avec le ministre de
l'immigration monsieur jallet barrette
êtes vous surpris de la tournure que ça
a pris je n'ai pas été surpris parce que
le gouvernement
du premier ministre hugo avait annoncé
la couleur cherche à réduire le nombre
de réfugiés réinstallés au québec et je
savais qu'on allait avoir un échange
certainement foutue mais aussi peut-être
un peu tendu parce qu'on ne voit pas les
choses de la même manière mais le
ministre a aussi reconnu à la fin des
notes discussions que les réfugiés était
un apport bénéfique à la province de
québec et je crois que c'est un point
important à retenir
mais c'est justement sur ce point
particulier de l'impact des réfugiés au
québec que ça a accroché dans votre
échange aujourd'hui en fait et je vous
cite ici vous avez dit que vous
déploriez que le gouvernement à ceux ci
réfugié dès que faire donc manifestement
cette phrase elle eu beaucoup vexé
monsieur gélébart est est ce que c'est
vraiment ce que vous comprenez de son
message on a mis un échange sur les
coûts à investir pour intégrer les
réfugiés que ce soit les demandeurs
d'asile qui passe au chemin de roxane ou
ceux qui sont installés de pays tiers et
amener directement dans les 14 régions
de la province du québec
et c'est vrai il ya un coup à faire
venir ces gens à les installer à
l'étrange iv à leur donner accès au
logement
mais on sait qu'après 10 ou 15 ans s'est
réfugiée payent plus de taxes que ce que
ce nous a coûté à nous contribuables
d'investir pour leur arrivée et leur
intégration donc c'est un pari gagnant
et je crois que sur ce point là tout le
monde peut reconnaître que les chiffres
sont là pour prouver
vous me résumer ici ce que vous êtes
venu dire devant cette émission parce
que vous étiez là pour convaincre
finalement le ministre les gens qui
l'entourent de l'apport positif des
réfugiés et du rôle qu'elle québec doit
jouer pour l'accueil aussi de ces
réfugiés mais mme inès lui à décoder
dans vos mots en fête et c'est comme ça
vous l'avez présentait d'ailleurs au
ministre vous avez dit vous associez les
réfugiés inferno est ce que c'est votre
compréhension du message je me suis
jamais barrette ou du message du
gouvernement de la caq qu'on a tendance
à faire cette association on préfère des
réfugiés économiques on préfère les
faire passer par le système animaux
finalement c'est pas des réfugiés et des
migrants
mais on préfère avoir moins
de réfugiés oui je crois vraiment qu'il
ya toujours un acte du vent sur sur les
finances nécessaires pour l'intégration
des réfugiés des nouveaux arrivants et
effectivement j'ai un problème avec le
fait que souvent dans le discours
politique de plusieurs partis ce n'est
pas limité à ce qui se passe ici au
québec on associe les réfugiés un
fardeau un poids économique a des gens
qui vont avoir besoin des bénéfices
sociaux pendant des années ce n'est pas
vrai les gens s'intègre correctement
apprennent le français trouve un travail
mettent leurs enfants à l'école et
deviennent des acteurs positif dans le
domaine économique culturel et social
et ça c'était un point qui est pour moi
était important de rappeler aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale du québec au
ministre mais aussi aux autres membres
de la commission
oui vous avez souvent ça c'est
d'ailleurs par le passé la
stigmatisation des réfugiés avec la
montée du populisme est ce que vous
faites ce constat là pour le québec on
le voit ici au québec on le voit surtout
le canada d'une côte à l'autre
malheureusement l'arrivée de 20000
personnes irrégulière par le chemin de
rock ça m'a changé un peu la nature des
discussions
et c'est bien malheureux parce qu'on se
rend compte que le québec a un savoir
faire extraordinaire en terme
d'intégration et au lieu d'être fier de
ce qu'on a fait pour intégrer que ce
soit les demandeurs d'asile de roxane où
les réfugiés réinstallés
on essaie de voir toujours le verre à
moitié vide
au lieu de voir tout la porte ou
l'enrichissement que ces personnes
apportent à la province et au pays en
général
oui vous connaissez la volonté du
gouvernement de la caq actuellement de
négocier avec le fédéral pour faire
baisser le ton de réfugiés qu'on
accueille ainsi dans la province au
profit de faire monter celui des
immigrants surtout ceux qui qui ont une
capacité d'avoir un emploi avant même
d'arriver finalement à tout le moins une
promesse d'emploi et d'aller en région
votre chiffre parfait
le chiffre d'accueil qu'on devrait avoir
au québec de réfugiés parce que moody's
est non seulement il faut le maintenir
mais il faut le aussi ça c'est quoi le
chiffre magique
il n'y a pas de chiffre magique et ça
c'est vraiment aux autorités tant
provinciales que fédérales de voir
quelles sont les capacités d'accueil
mais on a un élan extraordinaire
non seulement du ministère du ministère
de l'immigration au niveau de la
province de québec des autres provinces
de la même manière mais aussi de la
population québécoise on a tellement de
québécoises et de québécois qui se
mobilisent pour parrainer des réfugiés
je crois que c'est important qu'on
entende leur voie et que les élus
respectent les décisions aussi de ces
québécois et québécoises qui ont ce
devoir de solidarité vraiment bien ancré
en eux comme une longue tradition ici
alors je comprends vous plaît pas avancé
de chiffres ici ceci dit le binage et
les barrettes vous l'a bien dit
d'ailleurs vous le mentionnez vous aussi
le qu'avec ce qui s'est passé avec le
chemin roxanne dans les dernières années
on a eu soudainement beaucoup plus de
demandeurs d'asile que ce qu'on est
habitué d'avoir il ya une situation
particulière on est à côté des états
unis le tout le monde connaît la
situation
monsieur jean les barrettes vous a
expliqué aussi le fardeau financier que
ça représentait pour le québec parce que
ces gens là n'ont pas été répartis comme
le québec le demandait un peu partout au
canada donc en termes de structures
d'accueil en termes d'outils tout ça il
ya des sous il québec eu du mal à se
faire rembourser d'ailleurs avec le
fédéral là dessus est ce que on doit
tenir compte de ces facteurs là dans le
taux de réfugiés qu'on décide
d'accueillir par la suite c'est à dire
maintenir cet équilibre d'un côté on
veut port on veut pas fermer les portes
d'un autre côté on est conscient qu'un
fardeau financier mais aussi une
perception dans la population et que si
on pousse le bouchon un petit peu trop
loin on risque de créer ce que vous
dénoncez c'est à dire on risque de créer
un sentiment de fermeture ou les gens
vous écouter on a donné l'or aux jo ce
moment de me respecter notre capacité
aussi est-ce que vous êtes sensible à
cet enjeu le tout à fait sensible et je
comprends les préoccupations des
québécoises et québécois et du
gouvernement
maintenant il faut garder à l'échec
français très laid
et garder notre capacité de reconnaître
qu'on est capable de faire
vingt mille personnes ont traversé par
le chemin de roxane l'année passée et
l'année d'avant
cette année les chiffres sont un peu
plus bas c'est un pays de 37 millions de
personnes
je crois que le canada et la province du
québec ont la capacité de recevoir vingt
mille personnes qui arrivent et qui
arrive sur une période de 12 mois
je crois que le canada a la capacité
d'intégrer de donner du travail du
logement
on sait qu'il ya quelques mails et les
habitations temporaires pour ces gens
qui arrivent d'europe femmes sont à 40
pour cent lits libres vide en ce moment
donc ça veut dire qu'il y en a mis les
moyens et c'est important le fédéral a
aussi mis des moyens supplémentaires
financier à peu près 60 % de la facture
est payée par le fédéral pour qu'on
puisse accueillir séjournent les bonnes
conditions qui sont des gens qui n'ont
pas choisi de venir au canada mais qui
fuient la guerre les conflits des
persécutions politiques religieuses ou
d'orientation sexuelle
en bout de ligne là vous avez vu un peu
les manchettes la tournure que prend la
couverture de les changes que vous avez
eue avec monsieur des barrettes vous
l'impression que votre message est
entendu où c'est un peu raté
comment vous le percevez votre bilan de
la journée finalement non je crois que
notre message est très bien entendu et
qui résonne auprès de plein de québécois
devaient et québécois qui ont comme je
lé rappeler il ya un moment des valeurs
de solidarité d'humanité qui sont bien
ancrées dans les traditions ici qui
savent l'apport économique culturel que
les réfugiés apportent à leur communauté
qui se rendent compte que ces réfugiés
restent dans l'est dans les régions au
lieu de quitter pour aller vers montréal
ou toronto il reste dans les régions ils
font que ces régions très active et je
crois que tout un chacun de nous connaît
un réfugié et peut reconnaître la valeur
qu'il apporte à sa communauté d'accueil
cela suppose merci pour cette entrevue
mais c'est bien en vain merci